this video is sponsored by ridgewallet i
am
tired right now not necessarily because
i didn't like fishman island but
because my schedule totally fell apart
this week resulting in me needing to
read almost 60 chapters worth of story
in a day and a half and so as i'm
writing this i am holding my eyes open
at 1am after having read for what felt
like
a thousand years actually you know what
i don't think i should be writing a
script right now i'm too tired i'm gonna
continue this in the morning
eight hours later much better and to be
honest i feel like i have a much more
solid opinion of the story fishman
island has to offer now
last week i dipped my toe back into
reviewing the story of one piece with
the short but charming return to
shabaldi
which in a lot of ways acted as a setup
arc of sorts for this fishy boy
and let me tell you fishman island has a
lot going on
whether that's a good or a bad thing i
will explore in this episode so
welcome back everyone i'm totally not
mark and these are my first impressions
of thoughts on and review for
a tale 30 000 feet beneath the ocean's
surface
exploring personal prejudice loyalty and
tenacity
this is the turbulent the busy and the
foreboding
fishman island
all right so before i dive into this one
i want to touch on a couple of things i
neglected to mention
last week return to sebaudi was in
effect the prelude to fishman island and
without which wouldn't work nearly as
well
it acts as the reduction to the entire
crew who have all grown and changed
considerably since we last saw them two
years prior with
full redesigns sanji's hair is brushed
to the other side with some
facial hair zorro most notably has a
scar over his left eye which i'm sure
has a very interesting story behind it
that i don't know yet chopper has
remained largely the same aesthetically
with the biggest difference being that
of his hat
nami has aged up to become a grown woman
usopp is buff now with a little soul
patch goatee thing
robin's hair is different pushback i'm
not sure if i like it more or less and
no physical changes are obvious yet
frankie is a massive upgraded mechanical
man now and
brooke is a superstar which leaves luffy
whose biggest physical change comes in
the form of an
x-shaped scar across his torso acting as
a constant reminder of why it's so
important for him to get stronger to
protect those he loves
as a result of this love as well as all
the time they've spent training the crew
has literally
never been stronger taking out pacifists
with relative ease and
speaking of which bartholomew kuma the
real one
acting on its last shred of humanity he
protected the thousand sunny
until frankie arrived back at the
archipelago i don't know what this means
for the future but
i'm interested to see how dr vegapong
plays into future events overall i think
these redesigns are welcome and in many
ways inform the changes the characters
have undergone over the last two years
this being most evident with characters
like usup and zoro whose physical
changes echo the tribulations they
underwent
over the training period of the last two
years but with characters like frankie
and robin
i'm not sure if i like these redesigns
as much as the former but
who knows they might grow on me however
while keeping that in mind if fishman
island acts as anything
it's as a statement to the rest of the
world that the straw hats are here
and they are forced to be reckoned with
alright enough teasing and with a weird
long-tongued
creep pursuing them the straw hats dive
to the depths below not
knowing the adventure that awaits them
speaking generally before diving into
the story in greater detail i actually
really enjoyed this arc it's by no means
the best or even in the top five
i would say i got a little bit more
enjoyment out of this arc than i did
with little garden or perhaps the same
it doesn't do anything structurally
different to the prior acts of the story
and does some things here and there that
i didn't really enjoy
so much that i will explore in greater
detail later but overall i'm pretty
happy i read it it has some tender
moments and i'd totally be down to read
it again in the future sometime
fishman island is a story that finally
explores the rich history of the area
and its people that have since the very
beginning of the story being ostracized
and belittled for how they are it's a
story about prejudice and the means with
which to combat that on both sides
of this which is a really interesting
way of tackling the issue i think now
with that said i think it can be very
heavy-handed in parts with certain
characters devolving down to represent
the extremity of a certain ideology's
point of view
but overall i think it offers more good
than bad so let's talk about the setup
and how the story handles the first act
something that immediately caught my eye
as i'm sure it did with many of your own
when you first saw it was rayleigh's
farewell to the straw hats as he watches
them dive down to the depths below
teary eyed he recalls the time when he
first encountered roger
young and skinny brimming with a large
smile painted across his face
wearing a straw hat he asked really to
join his crew
and the rest was history but the fact
that roger has luffy's hat or has a hat
similar to luffy
has me thinking that straw hat roger was
wearing how did it come to be worn by
shanks okay
here's a theory and it's a bold one what
if shanks was the one to kill roger
what if shanks poisoned him and the
reason he went to look over luffy was to
keep
tabs on him by some mechanism he knew
that luffy was the one he knows now that
luffy is going to come all the way back
to him to deliver the hat
and maybe luffy growing into the person
he is today is important for something
he wants to achieve
he's an emperor of the sea and he was
the enemy of whitebeard for some time
we know that whitebeard's a good guy now
obviously there needs to be a few more
bits of setup and
an explanation needs to be delivered
upon but i think this could be really
cool
for the big bad and the hero of the
story to have been established in the
very first chapter
without anyone really knowing that would
be awesome but who knows
i could be completely wrong and probably
am besides i spent too long speculating
time to talk about fish stuff the star
of the story centers around the crew as
they make their treacherous way towards
fishman island and you think that once
they have the ship kitted out with
diving qualities that would be the most
difficult part
well it absolutely isn't and this is one
of the aspects of this arc i think work
in its favor to set itself apart from
the rest of the other arcs
this destination fishman island is the
most treacherous out of all the others
we've ever visited in the past
just like the rest of the crew we are
experiencing all of this in real time as
they dive
10 000 20 000 and eventually 30
000 feet below sea level where enormous
neptunians lurk and where light can't
reach
and unlike the other acts of one piece
that center around the exploration of a
particular island the journey to
fishman island alone is just as
action-packed and important as the
activity that goes down once they do
meet their destination
this brief but enthralling introduction
to the depths of one piece both inform
the story that we are to explore later
on but also introduces us to the
environment and a lot of the different
mechanics we will have to contend with
during this story like enormous mythical
creatures
and bubble suits that enable the likes
of those with devil fruit abilities to
navigate the water they're in
which by the way i thought was
introduced in an ingenious way if i'm
being perfectly honest you see
something we've not had to contend with
much in the series so far is
air oxygen levels in this story it plays
a massive role specifically because
it's in short supply a lot of the time
in various scenes
for instance the study that raleigh
coated has a membrane that can be
permeated but not to an extreme extent
meaning one or two individuals can punch
or slice through it but if too many at
once try
it won't end well which is a nice bit of
added attention to the group's
activities considering almost half of
them are devil fruit users
which by the way offered a lot in the
way of an opportunity for luffy to
demonstrate his character perfectly
throughout the treacherous journey down
through the depths of the sea
further and further the crew encounter
numerous obstacles and beasts they need
to flee from
and thankfully they can using the sunny
but the drawback is that it
uses oxygen which i mean on its own is
sort of cool to create tension
but it gets compounded when the
situation worsens leading to them all
running out of oxygen on the sunny when
they needed to make a split decision of
whether to run away or to keep the air
but the interesting part is
at no point does luffy waver
he has limitless resolve and belief in
his crew i mean if there was ever a
moment where the devil fruit user would
be feeling the pressure
it's right there surrounded by water
thousands and thousands of feet beneath
the surface
with only your crew to rely on but luffy
never stresses and i think that's why
he's so carefree it's not because he
thinks he has everything under control
it's that he trusts his crew
unconditionally and together he knows
that between them
there's always a solution that can be
found i mean he insists on befriending
the literal kraken in the middle of the
ocean twenty thousand feet beneath the
surface
how insane is that something also i
should bring up is that early on it's
brought to our attention that this creep
we last saw at zabaoti is pursuing them
however through unfortunate
circumstances for him he gets captured
by the straw hats and separated from his
own crew
make sure to remember him he becomes
very important later they also see the
flying dutchman ship on the way down
which becomes important later also
but needless to say they arrive on
fishman island which
by the way given the nature of its
inhabitants is a really weird name for a
place
it's like all of us calling our own
respective hometowns
humanberg or something then again maybe
one piece has really weird place names i
mean usopp is from syrup
village so it checks out but back to the
story what i like about the introduction
here also when they arrive on the island
is the struggle there is to actually
land the damn ship it acts as a way of
introducing us to all the issues that
navigating in 3d space instead of
sailing on the sea
involves in this place they are
surrounded by water
and once they do land where they want to
be they are unfortunately
submerged underwater in the ocean which
is a big problem but
thankfully
[Music]
acting as a nice reintroduction for the
character in the series as well as
offering the story an individual to give
us natural exposition for the world of
fishman island
and what's going on there and then so
let's talk about the big bloody-nosed
elephant in the room i
actually didn't mind sanji in this arc
i know that sounds sort of contradictory
and i don't find it really remotely
interesting but
it is what it is i don't actively
dislike it like i did the absalon scene
from thriller bark
in that sanji acted sort of like a creep
whereas here
albeit to a ridiculous extreme all he's
really doing is finding people
attractive and that's totally fine he
always did that but
what is funny about this to me is that
it's used as a mechanism to give the
crew a short-term
goal to drive the plot forward sanji was
deprived of seeing people he found
attractive for so long
that now the mere sight of an attractive
girl sends him flying into the sky
propelled by his own nosebleed
yes that is the sentence i just said
right now
this is literally the only anime i know
where the lustful nosebleed
actually has ramifications in the real
story which
is honestly kind of funny regardless
this creates the circumstances wherein
along with certain stresses imposed by a
sneak attack from the fishman pirates
the straw hats need to escape and find
sanji a suitable blood transfusion which
apparently requires a rare blood type
because sanji's blood type is rare
as viewers and readers this introductory
scuffle informed us of
three things sanji is a hopeless case
luffy has gotten
monstrously powerful and the laws of
fishman island are coloured by their
history
this particular circumstance while it
does meet a swift solution
it also shines a light on the two main
themes of this story
prejudice and forgiveness two themes
that i find incredibly compelling
personally
as i identify these as particular story
topics that are timeless
also while fleeing the scene where they
landed at the mermaid inlet
they encounter and ultimately run from
the princes of fishman island who happen
to have been pursuing the straw hats
with the goal of relaying them a message
from jinbei who's waiting for them at
the forest
of the sea they also want him to know
that he should not
fight a person by the name of huddy and
that's not even to mention this
character called madame charlie the boss
of the mermaid cafe where kami works
this was the place they settled on to
give sanji his blood transfusion
she has the ability to predict the
future using her crystal ball
and this very vision she has brings
about the end
of fishman island and the person
responsible she identifies as straw hat
luffy
and okay this is what i think was the
most jarring part of fishman island
because it's picking up right after a
break in the series with very little
build up from the arc prior it felt like
i was being bombarded with
dozens of new characters and it felt
that way because i was
remember what i said in a prior video
that at the beginning of these volumes
i'm reading there's a couple of pages
dedicated at the start to keep you up to
date with the relationships established
in the story
who people are and who they are allied
with remember that okay
well this is what the second volume of
this story shows us
wanna guess how many people i have to
keep track of i'll give you a hint it's
31.
that's a lot to remember for little old
me and as someone who needs to keep
track of the story's moving parts in
order to review their success and
failings
i found it almost overwhelming early on
with that said however this does improve
greatly as oda streamlines the story
relatively quick after this having spent
the first arc establishing a lot of the
characters in the story
explaining and demonstrating how the
world of fishman island works through
wildlife cultures belief systems
citizens as well as its technology and
infrastructure
this arc if nothing else is ambitious
and it's telling
so let's see how the story starts to
connect the dots and picks up
from this point it's at this point the
main plot thread starts to take a whole
of the story we're introduced to and get
to know two important antagonistic
characters for the ark
hardy jones captain of the new fishman
pirates and van der
danken captain of the flying pirates and
the flying dutchman ship which we saw
towards the beginning of the story both
of these characters effectively in one
form or another threatened to corrupt
and tear the island itself
apart as villains go i didn't personally
find them too interesting on an
individual level and they certainly lack
the same level of charisma other older
characters like arlong and crocodile had
but that's not to say that either of
them don't have anything to offer the
story
van der dekken is a crucial plot device
that allows the story itself to function
as smoothly as it does
possessing a devil fruit ability that
allows him to once he touches someone to
throw anything towards them
without missing now that sounds rather
unremarkable when set alongside other
more flashy abilities but it's this very
power that holds the foundations of the
plot together
that i will get into a little more later
on on the personality front decking is
more akin to a comedic sideshow attract
by no means the main force of the ark
and resembles something out of the wacky
racist cartoon more than an imposing
villain
now hoddy jones on the other hand i
really enjoyed but i should preface that
by saying that i think if he had been
used in any other setting or story he
would have been
a ludicrously boring character which is
to say that he works extremely well for
this particular story
and this story alone and this is made
all the more evident by how he turns out
at the very end of this arc
the reason why honey jones serves this
story so well comes down to what the
story is trying to achieve
as this tale unravels it comes more and
more to the forefront of the narrative
that racism and prejudice are at the
core of this story and a fantastic way
of exploring these
oftentimes complex concepts is by
pitting two extreme versions of the
ideology spectrum
against each other hoddy jones is one of
those extremes representing racism and
hatred in its purest forms
in arlang park we got some minor
exposition regarding his feelings on
human fishman relations but it was by no
means the main topic of the story
this time it is and hadi acts as a
terrific tool to communicate one side's
feelings on the topic
and once luffy and the crew meet the
royal family of the kingdom but most
notably the princess
they become as they often do caught up
in the complex turmoil the fishman
people find themselves embroiled within
as i said luffy usapanami are taken to
the palace by king neptune where luffy
meets princess
shirahoshi an enormous mermaid that has
been locked away in a room for 10
years hiding from one van der dekken who
relentlessly throws lethal weapons and
projectiles towards her from a very far
distance in an effort to kill her for
not
agreeing to marry him now naturally when
she meets luffy she is initially
reluctant to trust him at all
oh and as a quick aside this particular
arc is filled with moments where someone
asks luffy to prove himself but he never
once tries to convince
anyone of anything he is who he is and
he always lets his actions speak for
themselves he won't apologize for who he
is and
in this particular story where many
fishermen judge humans and
humans judge fishman it's a really
powerful use of luffy's character to fit
and contribute to this particular story
and once he successfully protects the
princess from an oncoming projectile she
feels safe enough to leave her tower to
explore the wider world
with him for the first time in a decade
which again
highlights luffy's character as someone
who no matter how significant or
powerful he is
will have no issue finding the time for
a single individual if they so need it
also she sneaks out inside her pet shark
megalo who's an absolute trooper in this
story by the way
however once her identity is eventually
let slip and she slides out of the
shark's mouth for all the public to see
they are forced to flee with her to the
forest of the sea where the most
significant sight of the ark
takes place it's at this location luffy
happens to find and meet up with jinbe
who was waiting specifically for luffy
here
if you recall towards the beginning of
the story he was the one who had sent
the three princes to relay a message to
luffy that message was to go to the
forest of the sea to meet with him
and to not fight hoddy jones good thing
he managed to get there without ever
receiving the message
now it's here we're greeted with a
flashback and perhaps the best part of
the story really for hundreds of
chapters now the history of these people
and the hardships they've faced
have been drip fed to us which obviously
creates anticipation but also offers
these flashbacks a strength the rest of
the story
doesn't really have much of which is
build up
we want to know about arlon's origins we
want to learn about fisher tiger and we
really want to learn about the queen's
story who has held an incredibly high
regard within this society after dying
tragically young so let's talk about the
flashback
[Music]
[Applause]
this video is brought to you by
ridge.com tnm most people are still
using wallets designed in the 1990s and
in this modern landscape it's seriously
outdated and i should know i've been
using the same wallet since i was 15
years old and that means i've been using
some outdated wallet for the last 14
years of my life
in the same way phones have gotten more
practical and compact over the last few
decades so too have wallets and
it's honestly made a massive difference
to my pockets personally i hate having
cumbersome items in there and this
totally fits my new lifestyle
it holds up to 12 separate cards plus
room for cash and there's over 30
different colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium to
choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their thirty thousand
five star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so confident
that you like it that they'll actually
let you test drive it for 45 days that
means you can send it back for a full
refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off
with free worldwide shipping and returns
and you can get all of this by going to
ridge.com
tnm and using the coupon code tnm
link is in the description
please listen miss kaya
has he harmed you
[Music]
the best thing about this flashback is
that it makes the entire climax of the
arc
far more interesting which is exactly
what a great flashback ought to do
recontextualize the story in a more
interesting way while exploring and
extrapolating from the core themes of
this narrative
providing more depth and intrigue these
flashbacks cover many years of struggle
from various points of view including
but not limited to
hottie jones as a kid vander dekken
fisher tiger jinbe
and arlong working beneath fisher tiger
as young men before both defecting
and the royal family to name but a few
primarily following the history of queen
otahime
something of thought also is that i
thought her design being that of a
goldfish
was inspired the goldfish in japan
symbolizes prosperity and children which
is fitting as this character's ultimate
goal is to free the future generations
of this cycle of hatred her people have
found themselves to be trapped in
i found her character to be charming and
incredibly sweet highlighted during a
specific series of events surrounding
the sudden arrival of a celestial dragon
demanding this and that of these people
he deemed to be far beneath them you
know
typical likeable celestial dragon stuff
of the entire crowd formed around him
otohime is the only one who shows any
ounce of compassion
and in a selfless act that embodies her
belief perfectly
she jumps in front of this despicable
human being to protect him from a
gunshot
the character of arahime is crucial to
the overall message of this story
as she embodies the overall goal being
that of forgiveness
but as i said she isn't the only
individual we see clear the pages of
these flashbacks and between fisher
tiger and the young jinbe and arlong
hoddy jones is exposed to some
horrid ideas from a very young age
ultimately leading him to carry this
hatred for no reason at all
potty is the example of what arahime was
trying to avoid
to fight against to prevent the next
generation from inheriting the hatred of
the past
and i thought that was covered really
well throughout this entire arc to be
honest
especially considering the one who
ultimately killed arohime is hadi as she
is to
him standing in the way of progress for
his race of people
after these flashbacks and other
compelling setup conversations take
place
my two favorites of the arc the first
being that of nami reconciling the fact
that jinbei was responsible for her time
under arlon
ultimately releasing him into the east
blue in the first place ending with her
ultimately forgiving him
for that but the second is by far the
most interesting for me it's the debate
that takes place between jinbei and
luffy after these flashbacks end
regarding what's the next step in
solving this hottie jones matter i
thought this was
genius and offered a very unique flavor
to the dialogue i hadn't felt really
since water 7 with usopp
both sides of this conversation have
their points luffy wants to take out
this murdering racist that wants to
bring about destruction and widespread
hatred but jimbei says quite rightly
that that will do more bad than good as
it will be yet another instance of
humans being cruel to fishman turning
hottie himself into a martyr which is a
really fascinating angle to take this
complex situation from
it's a surprisingly easy to understand
nuance point of view that stands
completely at odds with luffy's way of
thinking and so from that the new goal
becomes
how do they control the optics of the
situation how do they turn luffy
into fishman island's hero act three
this act much like the rest of the arc
isn't concerned primarily with plot but
more so the individual elements
contributing to and expanding upon the
given themes of the ark itself
does it work 100 yes and no on a
thematic level i think it works
perfectly fine but from a plot point of
view a lot of the characters who
interact in this arc feel less like
characters but more like stand-ins or
vehicles to deliver an idea specifically
for the ark and its themes
for instance hottie jones as i said
represents what could happen
he represents what happens when you
don't encourage the next generation to
forgive he even goes as far as to kill
his own kind to meet his
ends and even manages to get his hands
on a pill that amplifies his power in
exchange for time off of his life
and throughout the arc right up until
the end hoddy jones changes from a
youthful strong fishman
to a withered bigot with his hatred
being the direct cause
for his loss of life his own hatred
having taken his own freedom and youth
from him he is by no means a complex
character but
again an example to show everyone what
can happen if the thematic message
isn't successful because he's not much
of a character and only conceived for
this arc he gets locked away at the end
at a really old age
so i would be really surprised if he
ever shows up again and i'm sorry if it
feels like i'm
glancing over stuff but trust me i have
understood and appreciated
everything i've read here it's just
because the story really only has
one main plot thread active at any given
time there's so many things that have to
be explained in a single storyline like
i didn't even really talk about hoddy's
backstory or
fisher tiger story or arlong's origins
or van der dekken's history with the
flying dutchman and the reason
is is if i did all of it it would just
be recapping and this video would be
like two hours long
fishman island feels so dense
specifically because it only has
one plot thread from start to finish and
from a structural standpoint that's its
biggest difference between
all the other arcs who always had other
interconnecting plot threads at any
given time so for the sake of my mind
and your time you can rest assured that
i
thoroughly enjoyed that flashback for
fisher tiger and all the rest of them
and from this point on i'm going to pick
up right where jimbei megalo and
princess shirahoshi show up to confront
hadi in the public square
after he delivers a pretty
character-rich speech to the citizens of
fishman island
and for context narratively this also
takes place right after luffy and jimbei
had that argument over how best to deal
with this situation they're facing
tactfully
flanked by one hundred thousand pirates
backing his cause
stands hardy now with a head full of
withering white hair
and a massively different body the
results of his desire to indulge in this
power pill
this is where the story finally starts
getting into some decent action
madam charlie the fortune teller steps
forth from the crowd that has ultimately
turned on hottie jones
after his speech revealing to the crowd
what she knows about straw hat luffy
which quickly brings the crowd into
chanting for luffy to come and take care
of hottie
hottie has now become so monstrous that
even the fish men that are unsure of the
human race in general
are cheering against him and with
various chants for luffy echoing
throughout the area
out from megalo's stomach flies luffy
landing a massive attack on hoddy who's
scent
flying springing forth standing
alongside their captain
stand the rest of the straw head crew
they aren't interested in changing the
minds of or convincing anyone of
anything and this is our first chance to
see how powerful they really have become
and this fight is actually really tense
starting with something massively
impressive
luffy takes out half of the army 50
000 people with his hockey alone with
the rest of the straw hats left to deal
with the remaining
50 000. from this very section the part
that stayed with me the most as a
striking visual
was the moment luffy walks casually
through the hurricane of a battle
raging on before him unafraid and
undeterred straight towards hadi
allowing his crew
to clear the path toward him it's a
powerful moment demonstrating that luffy
has changed a considerable amount
over the last two years he is now a
force to be reckoned with
and to be honest luffy is way too
powerful in this instance for hadi to
prove to be a threat
even in the slightest which is why oda
makes use of the technology established
at the beginning of this story and thus
enter van der dekken to inject some
ridiculous stakes circumstances and
set pieces the dude throws a massive arc
called nod that has massive significance
which i'll speak on later but
anyway he throws the giant arc causing
it to follow like all the other
projectiles towards the princess
meaning it will crash into fishman
island if she doesn't move which means
now she has to flee the island and begin
swimming up into the area where luffy
can't protect her
and thus arise the perfect circumstances
for a handicapped fight between luffy
and hoddy
now both in pursuit of the boat hottie
mortally wounds and takes out deccan for
attempting to thwart his planet as a
result now the ship begins to plummet to
the island below
luffy in this time aided by the bubble
technology and the princes from before
take out hottie once and for all in an
incredibly cathartic way but this still
doesn't resolve the circumstances
the massive ship is still on a collision
course falling towards the island below
now i didn't mention this before but in
the flashback which i did a terrible job
of explaining
it reveals the key piece of information
that led to vanier deck in pursuing the
princess for the last 10 years in the
first place
it's her ability to communicate with the
neptunians
a gift that is granted to maybe one
individual every few centuries
which is a massive deal considering how
enormous the neptunians are in this
particular section but moreover
in this instance full of distress and
worry for her people and her island
while luffy is doing everything he can
to destroy the ship before it lands
she screams for him to stop this ship is
important for her people
and carries a tremendous significance
but also there's now
no need anymore having not known how to
control this power or that she even had
it
she manages to pull off this right at
the last
second and at the very end of this
battle luffy much like fischer tiger was
in his story
is left lifeless after a savage
encounter in desperate need of a blood
transfusion
however as it was established in the
beginning of the story giving blood to a
human is forbidden by law
and at the same time throughout this
story jinbe has been an incredibly
compelling character to follow as he
offered the story a ton of internal
conflict
raised to resent the society that put
his people into slavery even after
fisher tiger's passing he still held on
to both resentment
and shame for what his actions wrought
however jimbei
in this moment with luffy decides to not
hold on to anger
and gives luffy his blood again i didn't
mention this earlier but
during those flashback sequences we saw
how fisher tiger came to die it was his
decision to not accept the blood
transfusion of a human
he held on to hatred and thus died as a
direct result of it a blood transfusion
acting as a powerful example that we are
all made of the exact same stuff on the
inside but focusing on the outside is
what brought slavery about in the first
place and what ultimately brought about
his own demise
and reflecting on that jinbe acts as an
example for the older generations too
that you as well as the next generation
do not need to continue this
awful resentment and what makes this
story even more nuanced is that oda
accepts that there are those that will
never be able to feel like they can
forgive
and that can be okay too as long as you
don't instill this resentment in the
next generation
and to be honest i think that's a really
powerful message for
a story i mean as many of you might
already know i'm irish
i've lived in ireland my entire life and
in doing so i've become aware of
ireland's turbulent past with the
british empire in england and while
relations between ireland and the
british empire are relatively great
right now all things considered
regarding our history there are still
irish alive today that despise the
british for the past that we share and
perhaps it's because of my upbringing
but i really appreciated the angle that
this arc took
when discussing prejudice and
forgiveness often times during these
stories a massive amount of focus
is put on the racism side of the
argument and that's because it's the
obvious target and makes for a
compelling force to fight against
and it goes without saying that it
absolutely 100
is a force that should be fought against
but in these circumstances situations
are rarely cut and dry especially if you
extrapolate over a number of generations
and the fact is that these circumstances
will continue to affect every subsequent
generation until both sides reach an
eventual understanding and i love that
this story took the time to focus on the
forgiveness side of the argument
as it is in my opinion the single most
important and fascinating part to
explore within a story if i were to hold
english people my age responsible for
the sins of their great grandparents or
entire country for that matter then all
i'm doing is perpetuating this horrific
toxic mentality to future generations
to suffer through full of resentment and
hatred which not only isn't fair to them
and the english but also doesn't make
any logical sense
in fishman island they explore all of
that with the character of arahime
acting as the polar opposite to hardy
jones
her character effectively holds up a
mirror to us the audience and her people
for them and us all to see how ugly they
are becoming
and as i mentioned the stark contrast to
hardy jones the product of a
hateful ideology proving that if you
follow this resentment far enough you
become exactly what you hate
a prejudiced maniac obsessed with his
own race
fishman island and hoddy jones's
character tells a story of how choosing
hatred over forgiveness can lead to your
own self-destruction both on an
emotional
and physical level this is on display
throughout the entire story but my
favorite similarity i noticed was that
of nami and the former fishman slaves
just like the former slaves of fishman
island who morph their own tattoos to
represent something else
that they believe in so too did nami
change her arlong pyrus tattoo to
something else
effectively arlong did the exact same
thing to the humans
that he despised them for reinforcing
the notion that if you let the hatred
consume you
you start to become exactly what you
hate now before i wrap things up with
this review
i'd like to break down all the
interesting pieces of information and
lore that were revealed during this arc
first
and what comes to mind immediately is
the significance of the ultimate weapon
finally being revealed
way back in skype yet coordinates
pointed to this exact destination
and only now is it being explored and
uncovered that's mad
there's also this really interesting
moment where luffy asks jimbei right
after he saves his life
to join the straw hat crew and while he
doesn't immediately accept luffy's offer
due to his own need to take care of some
certain businesses he needs to attend to
i think it's a really nice little thing
left for us to look forward to in the
story whenever it does end up happening
that is
personally i think jinbe is a perfect
addition to the straw hat crew
also i didn't mention it during this arc
but robin wandered off to uncover a
ponoglyph in her own
sort of side story effectively
disconnected from the rest of it until
the very very end and on this particular
panoclip read an apology from one
joy boy who was revealed to have been
someone that lived during the void
century
800 years ago apparently he broke a
promise to the fish men but
they don't remember what it was for this
is obviously super important and i'm
sure it will be explained later but as
of right now i have no idea what to make
of it oh also
when the princess communicated to the
neptunians luffy understood what was
being said
that's massive and i'm guessing based
off of the brief flashback we got of
this exact situation happening with
roger hearing the neptunians is that
roger didn't know that he had this power
the fact that luffy could come to learn
the fact that he has this power
could be a game changer when it comes to
correcting history and revealing the
void century
in other news akainu the guy who heated
ace out of the picture is now the new
fleet admiral instead of aokiji who was
put forward by sengoku and apparently
okiji has now left the navy
additionally luffy started a mad beef
with big mom one of the four
emperors of the sea
and in an effort to make amends also
center a bomb by mistake which is
hilarious if this video alone hasn't
conveyed to you how insane
and detailed this particular arc is i
encourage you to check it out for
yourself
i personally very much enjoyed it and i
can sort of feel how things are building
to something significant yet again and
i cannot wait to see what's to come for
us in this series but
with a farewell pinky promise i gotta
say that this is the end of the video
as always i've been totally not mark
i'll see you all next week
and thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you